guidé la réponse mondiale à la crise du
climat c'est l'ambition de joe biden
dans la lutte environnementale le décrit
d'aujourd'hui contribuera à renforcer
cet engagement en travaillant avec
d'autres pays pour soutenir les plus
vulnérables face aux conséquences du
réchauffement climatique et pour
accroître notre résilience collective
cela inclut un sommet réunissant les
leaders mondiaux que j'inviterai pour
aborder cette crise climatique cette
année lors de la journée de la terre
date de ce sommet le 22 avril 2021 jour
anniversaire de l'accord de paris une
initiative pour réchauffer les relations
internationales des états unis autour du
climat
le pays était sorti de son cadre sous la
présidence de donald trump préserver
l'environnement
une ambition internationale mais aussi
nationale objectif le retrait progressif
des énergies fossiles sur le territoire
américain
contrairement aux administrations
précédentes je ne pense pas que le
gouvernement fédéral devrait faire des
cadeaux aux grandes compagnies
pétrolières pour leur accordant des
subventions à hauteur de 40 milliards de
dollars pour les combustibles fossiles
je vais aller devant le congrès pour
demander de supprimer ces subventions
nous allons investir l'argent dans des
emplois liés aux énergies propres en
amérique le but parvenir à une
neutralité carbone dans le secteur de
l'énergie d'ici 2035 des annonces en
présence de john kerry ancien secrétaire
d'état sous la présidence de barack
obama a nommé la semaine dernière
envoyé spécial du président pour le
climat une fonction inédite qui
symbolise à elle seule l'importance du
sujet pour le nouveau locataire de la
maison blanche
mais si le président américain pourra
compter sur l'appui des démocrates ils
risquent d'affronter un vent de révolte
des producteurs d'énergies fossiles et
des républicains en attendant le vote du
congrès avec ce décret baden creuse un
peu plus le fossé avec la politique
énergétique de trump